hello good morning and welcome to Sophie
Ridge on Sunday Rishi sunak is at the G7
in Japan facing questions about China
support for Ukraine and the details of a
speed awareness course last year he
didn't seem best pleased to be quizzed
on whether his Home Secretary asked
civil servants to organize a private
course after she was caught speeding
last year and what labor say could be a
breach of the ministerial code the man
who promised a government of Integrity
has already lost three cabinet ministers
in the seven months he's been in charge
so we'll be trying to get to the bottom
of it all on the show today
will our first guests be able to shed
any light in just a moment we'll hear
from the environment secretary to
release coffee and for labor we'll talk
to the shadow Health Minister and
one-time leadership candidate Liz
Kendall we'll also be joined this
morning by the conservative mayor of the
West Midlands and the former John Lewis
boss Andy Street
Serenity Saladin is a renowned historian
he's been a university Vice Chancellor
he's now head of Epsom college and he's
been warning about the threat to
education from AI he'll join us live
plus there's not much that baroness
Marvel Lane Fox hasn't done in the world
of business she founded lastminute.com
she's now president of the British
Chambers of Commerce and She Will Be Our
Guest later
[Music]
foreign
shall we with the government the
environment brief is particularly in the
news at the minute giving the focus on
the water industry and the state of our
rivers and beaches so this week we are
talking to the environment secretary
Therese coffee I started by asking about
the prime minister at the G7
and thank you so much for being on the
program this morning it's been a big day
in the G7 we've just been hearing from
Russia the prime minister at the same
time Russia claiming victory in the
Ukraine what's your understanding of the
situation on the ground
I'm conscious that the president's
Ukraine is with the G7 at the moment and
has been there to continue that
International
resilience and also against the
oppression of Putin in invading Ukraine
which of course has had a devastating
impact on that country but The Economic
Consequences as well around the rest of
the world so I think it's right that the
UK committed to sending long-distance
missiles it's great news that President
Biden has agreed to be training the
pilots providing the airplanes so all
these things come together to show that
the world is United against Putin
um Richie sacks also said that China
poses the biggest challenge in his words
of our age to Global Security and
prosperity increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad
how big a problem is China
well I think China is now being one of
the largest economies in the world it's
uh that careful steps that we need to
take with them in terms of recognizing
this isn't about decoupling situation
but working closely with them but that's
also why we took decisions for example
to remove Huawei from our 5G Network a
conscious of the concerns about possible
Espionage and different ways that other
activities could happen that would
support the Chinese regime but I think
it's critical that we continue to make
sure we have our eyes wide open that's
why we opened our doors to people coming
from Hong Kong to have permanent
residency here in the UK when changes
were happening in in Hong Kong and it's
that sort of element where I think we
need to I say have tread a careful step
with them
um okay thank you um I'm Keen to talk
about some domestic issues now if I may
um is it true that the Home Secretary is
Wella bravaman asked civil servants to
arrange a private speed awareness course
after she was caught speeding well I've
only read the newspapers like your good
self I haven't got any extra information
that uh not wear any further details on
that it's perfectly normal nowadays if
people are found speeding to be offered
points or to go on a course of some kind
I say I don't know the details that are
referred to in the newspaper but I think
uh I'm sorry I'm aware the home
secretary's just decided to take the
points pay the penalty and keep focused
on her main job of um uh security but
also tackling illegal migration do you
have the home secretary's phone number
do I have her phone number I probably do
somewhere uh why didn't you message them
well because I think it's a case of uh
there's some speculation in the
newspaper I'm not going to get into
individual details
um as far as I'm aware there's people
close to the message so whoever the the
Press but you know candidly this is just
a case of um something that happened I
guess over a year ago I don't quite know
the details I can only read what is I'm
only aware of what was in the newspaper
do you get why viewers might find it a
bit frustrating
that
businesses can come on and say look I
don't know the details I've got nothing
to say on this because I just don't know
when you know it's it's obvious that
we're going to ask about this question
right why haven't you read the
newspapers myself probably about 20
minutes ago so I'm just scanning through
what was uh what's on the first page of
two of them well indeed it's not like
it's a kind of page 32 buried lead
indeed Sophie but uh as a people every
day get off of the joys of taking points
or doing a course of course there's more
there about how it's having a one-to-one
the issue isn't whether or not she does
the course no one would raise an eyebrow
if she was caught speeding and did a
course the issue is the allegation that
she asked civil servants to try and get
her a private speed awareness course I
mean that's clearly not in the room of
what civil servants are supposed to do
is it
well I think it's a case of uh reading
that um it was decided that civil
servants shouldn't get involved in that
that's quite this that's the details
that I just don't have Sophie and uh I
don't make it my business to go around
phoning people at uh 20 past seven in
the morning when I've just read a bit of
newspaper to look into this do you know
do you just don't think it's a big deal
if it's true then because you seem to be
quite relaxed about it it is a big deal
isn't it she's asking the
taxpayer-funded Civil Service to get
involved in her personal affairs I think
that
um what I've said is I've scanned the
newspapers myself this morning before
coming on the show I'm not in the
business of phoning people at about 20
past seven in the morning to try and get
chapter and verse from or even they
might have broken the ministerial code
uh I might be worth the message surely
well I mean you're making all sorts of
allegations there's different elements I
mean I'm just not aware of the details
uh Sophie and as I say at the same time
uh what i is clear is that she the
swella now has those three points in a
license and she's getting on with the
job about out tackling particularly
legal migration but also the wide
security elements of our country I'm
just
I'm not really making allegations
because I don't know what happened
that's why I'm trying to find out you
know her spokesperson saying she accepts
she was speeding last summer and regrets
doing so she took the three points and
paid the fine last year I mean that is
asking answering a completely different
question the question is did she ask
civil servants to get involved in what
many would see to be an abuse of power
well you've read the same things that
I've read in the newspaper as well this
morning I don't have any more details
than that and it's not for me to start
speculating about what did or didn't
happen
okay I I I I'm not really sure what to
say to be honest um okay that's that's
the position okay the timing of the
league or the story is also quite
interesting it's not going to be an easy
week for the Home Secretary with net
migration figures coming out expected to
have gone up significantly
um could net migration hit a
record-breaking 700 000.
well again I'm not going to speculate on
what's uh make the statistics may be
coming I think there are two key points
that I'd like to make which are that
since leaving European Union we now
control through an Australian style
points-based system
um the criteria for people coming into
this country
um who don't already have the
opportunity to do so we've also opened
our doors to people from Hong Kong from
Ukraine in really difficult
circumstances so the point is the rules
are there if we decide that we want to
change the laws in the future but
overall the Prime Minister has been
clear he wants to reduce overall numbers
on legal migration but the main focus
right now is actually on tackling the
illegal immigration that's why he was in
Iceland last week at the Council of
Europe making the case about what we are
doing with our illegal migration bill
but also that New Deal working with
frontex the European Union's body to
make sure not only around the channel
but of course people coming into Europe
in the first place so you know new
partnership is being forged there which
is really good use in trying to stop
illegal migration overall I'm Keen to
stick to Illegal migration if I may
um let's just have a look at what the
current situation is because it really
has been going up at a rate of not
recently I mean you can see it here um
the absolute spike in net migration to
the UK at over 500 000 as you say we
should see an excess he wants to bring
that number down he thinks it's too high
so how are you going to do that
well I think uh one of the things as
I've indicated we've already seen a
significant number I think it's well
over a hundred thousand people coming
from Ukraine
um there's also tens of thousands of
people who've come from Hong Kong and
still have the opportunity how are you
going to bring that number down but in
terms of
um I think it's a will be a case that
the home office will have been analyzing
the different sources of what's been of
people who've come in you know we
deliberately have uh this focus on
skills we deliberately have this focused
on people wanting to come to this
country and fill key gaps that we need
help with now but also a significant
element this is also about our
world-leading universities and about how
people want to come and study here as
well so there's a combination of factors
and it really is for the home office to
analyze and suggest different ways on
how we might want to tackle that in the
future
um it is of course the home office but
your view matters as well right because
I think the whole point of this is it's
quite hard to get some of the stuff
through Catholics people have different
views on how far you should go and
trying to bring some of those numbers
down so there's some the telegraph
obviously brief this morning that the
Home Secretary wants to curb student
visas by reducing the two years that
people can stay after they graduate do
you think that would be a good idea
well um also being cabinet means we have
Collective responsibility Sophie so it's
not about personal views it's about
taking that overall approach on what it
is the prime minister's set a clear
priority about stopping boats to stop
illegal migration
well I was about to say but he's also
made clear
um especially reinforcer over the
weekend about how we bring those numbers
down so how do you bring them that's
literally the question I'm asking how do
you bring those numbers down well I
think that the home office is working on
that sort of analysis right I mean like
can you see that's not really I mean
you're not really answering what I'm
trying to get like what how I understand
but I can't talk about policy that isn't
yet policy of government so uh at the
moment uh we've had to take it like take
it on word then that the numbers will
come down magically uh because the Prime
Minister said that I think um uh you
showed me numbers from last year I think
uh seeing that increase some of that can
be explained as I say by the number of
people coming from Hong Kong and Ukraine
also about different skills sure well we
have a look for policy uh that isn't
just frankly uh
um well not decided within government I
then can't go into speculation about
what it may or may not be let's have a
look at the breakdown uh shall we
because you're right there are different
elements of this the the um blue line at
the bottom there is Hong Kong and
Ukraine which as you say has gone up
um but then of course the blue the
lighter blue line above that is people
in work and that orange line at the top
is is students so so as you can see that
is the breakdown let's talk about
something that is a bit more in your
remit then hopefully might be able to
get a bit more uh guidance on that
um work visas obviously as you can see
from the chart big part of net migration
and your department promised Farmers up
to 55 000 visas for fruit Pickers next
year the Home Secretary says there's no
good reason we can't train freak Pickers
at home so so where is that argument at
have you had some difficult
conversations with the Home Secretary
about it well the farming industry quite
regularly relied on people coming in
from other parts of the European Union
potentially uh further to do this sort
of work and since the we've left the
European Union millions of people have
gained EU settlement status but of
course we've had covered and quite a lot
of people who were in the UK went back
to their countries uh uh across the
Europe and haven't necessarily come back
so it was important to try and fill that
Gap that's why the seasonal agricultural
workers scheme was started first of all
it's quite a small number and we
listened to this sector and that's why
we have the 45
000 number this year with potential for
an extra ten thousand now at the food
and farm to Fork Summit last week we
gave the certainty for next year that
we'd have the same numbers available
because one of the things that farmers
have said to us is that they want to be
able to plan ahead and so it's a balance
between what's going on with Automation
and the investment in that but indeed I
want to when I was at DWP we all at
local job center we tried to put Farmers
together with people seeking work and so
there's a variety of ways that we want
to try and do that but in the short term
I think uh certainly uh having that
certainty for next year was very much
welcomed by farming industry I just want
to kind of zoom out for a minute because
you know for many people can I just
point out those numbers don't count
towards the migration because people are
here for six months so it's literally
seasonal worker and then people go home
no it's an important Point
um just to sort of zoom out for a minute
you know for many people the rising
numbers of net migration that the PM
says he wants to bring down is a sign
that the government is out of control
you haven't got control of these numbers
I think we do have the control because
we've set the rules and you've seen
there the biggest increase by far
comfortable then with with the with the
higher numbers well the biggest increase
so far has been the number of people
coming to study here
now our universities are very keen to
have people coming from around the world
we also see it as a great way to
potentially attract Talent if uh if it's
easier to go and study in the USA or
elsewhere at the same time while we have
I think it's uh four of the top 10
universities in the world by
International rankings it's critical
that we try and make sure that people
have access to that Excellence
um because some of these things are
about building relationships not only in
the short term but in the longer term
and Britain's always been an outward
looking country uh and uh but one of the
things is about as I say the increase
that particularly happen with students
but also with Ukraine and Hong Kong
another example that some people may say
is a government that's not in control of
sewage in your department dirty Rivers
dirty beaches 300 000 spill events in
England last year is The Situation
acceptable
well I don't think it's acceptable but
that's why the water companies are
already under a criminal investigation
and that investigation was initiated I
think it was last year there's also uh
investigations being done by the
economic Regulators so together the
environment agency and of what are got
that combining congregation are you
angry towards the water companies I have
to say I'm pretty fed up with the water
companies and we've seen an apology this
week uh which is the right thing for
them to have done I think what's
important is to make sure that we have a
plan and we set out a plan for water to
try and Tackle these issues and let's
just bear in mind people didn't know
about these things until it was just
over a decade ago it was a conservative
Minister Richard bennion who initiated
that we're going to start making sure
all these sites were monitored all of
that will be completed by the end of the
year and that information is publicly
available I guess um some people might
say look you've got a plan but is it
enough and water companies have to
improve storm overflows you know that
effectively allows them to discharge
this sewage into our waterways to avoid
them going to games but not until 2035 I
mean you can't wait 10 years to have a
swim well there's a combination and by
the way our bathing waters are cleaner
than ever before so in terms of we've
seen an increase it's not a great
situation you've said it's not
acceptable situation well what I've what
I'm saying to you though is the water is
cleaner than it was in 2010 so 93 of our
bathing waters are excellent or good
that's an increase from about 70 in
2010. that's taken ongoing investment uh
to make that happen but in terms of uh
things like the storm overflows we are
dealing with the Victorian Network this
is where you have also combined uh
sewers taking not any stuff coming out
of your homes but stuff out of rain
water uh up until the 60s that is the
sort of investment that needs to be
fixed as well as the storm overflows but
it's why I insisted that by the end of
next month every single storm action at
storm overflow has to have an action
plan on my desk and we will go through
that and what happens if it's not good
enough what we do we will go back and
make make sure uh through our different
Regulators that that gets fixed okay but
in terms of the 10 billion that was
announced last last week by water UK
that's welcome but I have to say it's
similar to what we were expecting as
part of our overall 56 billion pound
storm production overflow plan but these
things do take time we're right by the
Thames the Thames but it's it's Bill
payers isn't it not that not the
companies you're going to be paying that
money right well I was just going to
talk about the scale if we're we're sat
right by the Thames right here that
project uh started about a decade ago
it's still not finished it's a huge
investment but that will be completely
reduce it to it it's bill pay us to be
picking up the town for this right well
we've had a record amounts of investment
into that is that yes or no it is yes
right through different ways it's going
to be a combination of course penalties
and fines are paid for by the company
not by the bill payer but in terms of
General payments I think uh you're right
to say that a lot of this investment
gets repaid through by bills it has a
small amount of return but I think in
the time that uh labor was in power 97
to 2010 over 30 billion pounds was
played out in dividends uh in terms of
the last decade in a way what's
happening and what's going forward the
dividends will be significantly lower
than what had happened in the past
should there be division at all should
there be making uh profits at time when
Bill payers the ones who are having to
pay for what the awful uh what has
happened before well one of the things
that off what does is to make sure that
any Investments are deemed to be good
value for money uh one of the things uh
that uh also this penalties can end up
with re reimbursements uh to customers
but I think it's critical to say that we
are getting to grips with a situation
that we have unveiled that scourge of uh
sewage and that's why our plans I think
will be effective in getting these
Solutions fixed now you're announcing
plans to strip out red tape in the wine
sector what's the idea
so we've been looking at a variety of
regulations uh from the European Union
at the moment things like wine they're
governed by 400 pages of regulations we
think a lot of that can be stripped away
and make sure that frankly this should
produce uh potentially up to 50 pence
off the cost of a bottle of wine so it's
about making sure we take advantage of
the fact that we can set the regulations
uh in the future get rid of the
bureaucracy and make sure not only our
thriving Vineyards at home we've got
about 800 of those now can really take
full advantage of the opportunities but
also reduce the red tape for some of the
wine coming in from abroad too so that's
a good way to toaster the forthcoming
summer and we'll get on with the
regulations as quickly as we can okay
thank you very much thank you
uh trees coffee there who hadn't seen
the suelo problem story we're led to
believe until shortly before the program
so not really giving too much of a view
on that one well let's get the view from
labor now uh shall we I'm sure Liz
Kendall and let's guess maybe a bit more
forthcoming on the soil of bravaman
situation the party's also setting out
its vision for the Health Service which
is struggling with the aftermath of the
Kobe pandemic and so we're going to talk
now to the shadow Health Minister Liz
Kendall thank you for being on the
program
um you'll have seen the reports about
swella bravaman and whether or not she
asked civil servants to arrange this
private speed awareness course for her
what's your reaction I think Rishi sunac
should launch an investigation into it
he should ask the independent advisor
whether she's breached the standards of
the ministerial code here I think a lot
of people watching this program will
think you know why is it always one rule
for them and another rule for everybody
else but you know Zoella government's
got got form on this hasn't she you'll
remember she actually had to resign as
home secretary under Liz truss because
she sent confidential documents to a
Tory MP when she shouldn't have done
that and Rishi sunak reappointed her as
Home Secretary why because he had to
keep the right wing of his party on
board so there's no point in him getting
all techy at the G7 press conference
it's it's because of him that she's
there so I've got my own views about
that sort of behavior but actually what
she what he should do is launch an
investigation to make sure we get to the
bottom of this and to see whether she
has actually breached the ministerial
code and I guess what Defenders of
cyrilla problem might say is that there
isn't really one rule for her and one
for everyone else because she did try to
do the speed awareness course and then
in the end ended up accepting the points
in her license
but why why did she ask civil servants
you don't forget she's the Home
Secretary asking civil servants whether
there should be a different Arrangement
that the rest of us have to have for her
is that the highest standards of
property and integrity that we should
rightly see from our ministers I don't
think it is but actually what sunak
should do is launch that investigation
or have more on the story of course
um as it develops as the day goes on
um The Wider story on when it comes to
homosexual of course is the net
migration figures we're expecting out uh
next week Richard's been very clear he
says that he wants to bring net
migration down from the current levels
of around 500 000 he thinks it's too
high what's the latest position is that
too high do you want to see it come down
I expect it to come down and it should
come down and I think the real issue
here is this that in Labor's
points-based immigration system we have
to tie up what we're seeing in terms of
a skills Gap in our population and
actually put in place the programs to
deal with that so that we don't have to
have the work visas that we're seeing at
the moment I mean just look at Health
and Social care that is the area where
the highest number of visas are being
issued at the moment but what does the
government do it cuts Medical School
places this year by three thousand
denying opportunities for bright young
britons to have a fantastic job in our
NHS social care the government we've
just heard has halved the funding it
promised in its white paper for the
social care Workforce so that is the
wrong approach where we have skill
Scouts labor said we will set up skills
for England to identify where those
problems are and put in place those
proper trainings it's interesting to
talk about a health sector and in terms
of those migration figures because as
you say we do see a huge number of
people coming from abroad to work in our
house service nurses doctors care
workers
is that a problem
I think we should be doing more to make
sure we have the proper training in this
country why is that is it because it's a
risk to rely on people no no because I
think it is a fantastic career and
opportunity I look in my own sector of
social care you know care workers do
some of the most important work in this
country looking after the people we love
most our elderly and disabled relatives
I think this is a huge area of growing
demand in future we know that our
population is aging and I also think by
having properly trained and paid care
workers in every part of the country
that will make a huge contribution to
our economy too so let's Champion that
rather than undermine it tomorrow
because Thomas giving a speech on the
NHS who's going to say the NHS is not
sustainable unless we make serious deep
long-term changes so what are the
changes what what what's the idea so
when the NHS was created average life
expectancy was 63. now it's 80 and one
in four babies born today is set to live
to 100. back then the major cause of
death and disease was infectious
diseases and accidents now it's
long-term chronic conditions like cancer
heart disease and diabetes a quarter of
us are living with two long-term
conditions or more and a third of people
who end up in a e have five conditions
or more our NHS is not set up to deal
with those problems what's the idea the
big thing is to get the shift towards
prevention early intervention and more
support in the community at home it's
about bringing together all these
separate teams into one place if you've
ever had to deal with an elderly
relative stuck in hospital you have to
battle your way around the system
ringing five six seven people what we
need is one team to help keep people up
so when you talk about prevention
one of the things the leaders of the
government have is regulation so taxes
for example on sugar more regulation
around junk food is that what labor
would do we do want to see a ban on junk
food advertising targeted at children
and young people what about taxes on
unhealthy food I think what we have seen
with the the sugar Levy is that that one
of the things the government has done is
that has made a difference so we will be
looking and you'll forgive me for not
making all the announcements today
you'll have to wait and see until the
mission tomorrow it is about Shifting
the focus towards prevention but it's
also about transforming those Services
if you're comfortable about making food
more expensive at a time when people are
really struggling to pay for food
actually I've I've seen here in the past
when when labor was in government that
actually having a a fair regulatory
system where you are taking action on
sugar and salt in people's Foods did
make a difference but I would say to you
too here Sophie it is a about far more
than that it is about radically Shifting
the focus of services out of hospitals
and into the community joining them up
around the needs of patients and users
because that's what we need to live
longer healthier more independent I know
we'll get more details tomorrow always a
slight frustrating time
to be completely honest with you as a
result
um now Kirsten says money's part of it
but it's not just about money but money
is a part of it as well you know you're
talking about social care right and big
problem the reason we've got so many
vacancies in Social care is that you can
earn more money working at a supermarket
so why would you stay in Social care can
I just come back labor labor say they
want a national Care Service there's as
much ambition as the 1945 NHS
realistically is labor looking at
putting up taxes in order to fund some
of the changes no and can I just come
back to you on that point I actually
used to say the same it is true that you
can earn more working in Supermarket or
Hospitality but actually a third of
people one in three who leave the care
Workforce actually go and work for the
NHS okay so we need to joined up
Workforce plan there but I'm talking
seriously about money right because
you're talking about huge you're talking
about 1945 style Reformation of a
national Care Service you're talking
about chronic Staffing shortages are you
looking at potentially wealth taxes the
reason I'm asking this is back in 2021
Kirsten was asked how he would fund an
increase in Social care funding he says
those that earn their money in ways
other than work should pay their own
share people who earn their money from
properties dividend stock shares they
should be looked at so that was back in
2021 I assume you have been looking at
it are you looking at wealth taxes to
try and we're not and you'll know that
I'm not going to sit here and pluck out
figures out of nowhere when goodness
knows what the state of the economy will
be by the time of the next general
election we've been pretty honest where
we do want to see increases in
investment where we'll get the money
from we've said that we'll scrap the
non-dom tax status in order to fund the
biggest Workforce expansion in the nhs's
history ten thousand more nurses
doubling the number of medical school
places five thousand more districts
that you're planning the biggest
transformation since 1945 when the NHS
was created if you're not saying that
there's going to be any more money to
fund it
but whilst extra investment is essential
what I would argue here Sophie is reform
is absolutely part of it too sure that
why have we got why have we got but we
have said where we'll increase funding
tax status yes
you may not well I don't think money
alone is the solution and if you don't
think 10 000 more nurses are doubling
the number I'm registering whether you
can do a reform similar to 1945 when
you're talking about you know around
five six billion pounds extra money
it's about reform why why does a family
have to ring six or seven different
numbers to try and get the services that
their elderly parent needs why don't we
have one team because there's one person
and they don't see their needs in
separate service silos reform can make a
huge difference if you look at delayed
discharges from hospital
1.7 billion pounds spent last year on
elderly people in hospital who didn't
need to be there imagine the difference
that could make if that was spent in the
community or at home reform alongside
investment is what we need to make the
NHS fit for the future okay thank you
very much for being on the program Liz
Kendall uh there for the labor party we
were watching at safety Ridge on Sunday
busy show this morning NHS G7 and of
course a lot on the latest sir
Brotherman allegations to still to come
on the program this morning next up
we're going to be talking to the
conservative mayor of the West Midlands
and the former John Lewis boss Andy
Street and a bit later on we'll be
hearing from the president of the
British Chamber of Commerce and much
more besides baroness Martha Lane Fox
[Music]
what Regional Mayors have become an
increasingly important part of our
politics and especially of course with
some of these new Devolution deals
expanding their powers where Andy Street
a former John Lewis boss has been the
conservative mayor at the West Midlands
since 2017. not a traditional concept of
Heartland fair to say but he joins us
now live thanks very much for being uh
with us I'm Keen to get your view on all
sorts of things
um but just to start kind of big picture
the conservatives have had a pretty
disastrous set of local election results
and there is a real challenge for Rishi
sunac at the next election you of course
represent an area where you know you're
used to winning against labor you're
used to fighting tight uh seats and
scrapping for votes if you like what do
you think the conservative party needs
to do now to deliver on what it says
it's going to do and I don't just say
that as a sort of glib response I say it
on the basis of very firm evidence in
the West Midlands and the elections we
had three weeks ago now actually the
conservatives in the West Midlands
combined Authority did not lose a single
seat we held three Metropolitan councils
they're the only ones in the country and
the reason why strong local leadership
in those areas were delivering on what
people wanted to say see it's quite
interesting when you say it's delivering
on what you've said already because
there will be some people who say you've
got to change the message look at what's
just happened the voters have basically
sent a really big message they're sick
of what the conservatives are doing they
don't like the direction of the
government is they're not times change
course no definitely not it's time to
deliver on the five things the Prime
Minister has said and again that the
clear evidence on the ground that that's
what people really are worried about NHS
waiting list as you've already been
talking about of course the migration
statistics as you've been talking about
but also all the underlying economic
pieces and my read of the uh of the
results actually we had good results in
the West Midlands as I say but across
the country there was no surge towards
labor there was disenchantment from our
voters I accept that but they're still
waiting to see if we can turn it around
still on course to win the next time
necessarily many of the supply disagree
with that they did not do well enough to
win the next election on those numbers
it was our voters saying maybe not to
get a majority but to win and to get
into number 10. in a sense we're talking
about the process the question you asked
me is what have we got to do deliver and
I'm saying our voters are still waiting
to see if we can do that and I'm very
confident with time they will certainly
the direction of travel in terms of
where we were last Autumn and where the
Prime Minister has now got us to is much
better
um let's talk house building yes because
I know this is an area that you're very
interested in
um and it feels like there's a bit of a
battle within the conservative party
about what to do on house building
whether or not you should support local
communities who are worried about
developments on the Green Belt whether
or not actually the conservatives needs
to build houses to really
help at what many families are calling
out for where do you sit so thank you
for asking the question because the
story in the Sunday Times this morning
partly why I'm trying to that tries to
pitch me against the government and
frankly I'm amazed that that's their
take on it because it's definitely not
my view the first thing to say is that
the government is achieving much
improved housing numbers compared to
dare I say the last Labor government 232
000 homes last year doubled the number
in 2010 and the reason I think we've got
something to say on this is that in the
West Midlands uniquely and the times did
confirm this we're achieving our housing
Target numbers and the way you do that
is you do have to take tough decisions
in favor of house bills what's your
what's your message then because you say
look you need to take this decision and
there are many MPS who would disagree
with that on your side that actually
look we've got to listen to The Logical
communities one of the tough decisions
where we can definitely come together is
about Brownfield first I have been
absolutely robust about this over the
last seven years so have our councils
cross party in the West Midlands and as
a result of that it is encouraging
developers to attend to the tough sites
in the Brownfield areas that's not an
easy decision it requires densification
of our city centers that's being done
and of course it requires a lot of
public money to enable those Brownfield
sites to come back to use Greenbelt if
necessary occasionally okay you can
never say never so let's give a good
example huge investment going in around
hs2 for The Interchange station in solid
Health the council there have been very
brave and say we will have development
around that to make the most of it but
it is very much the exception to the
rule if you don't get it right on house
building do you think that the
conservative party risks alienating a
whole group of Voters younger voters you
can put it much more positively than
that actually and it goes back to the
first question as well if I look at the
councils where we did really well we
were demonstrated bringing derelict land
back to life we were building the homes
we were doing the Regeneration of our
town centers and as a consequence those
young people see yes the conservative
party is the party that delivers for us
and that's the opportunity for us and
you talk about the economy as well
um and I want to talk a bit about
migration and because migration figures
are out next week they could hit 700 000
they're already at five hundred thousand
which is unex says that's too high and
that they need to come down but of
course if you look at the numbers
students work visas some would say that
this is immigration that we need what do
you think so the answer is it's again
it's not simple but binary like that we
do need skilled migrants in some key
areas so one of the sectors that the
government is talking a lot about at the
moment is the new industrial sectors
such as the electric vehicle sector we
do need people to come with those skills
but we actually have to deal with the
underlying issue about the lack of
skills in our own population so one of
the other things we're absolutely
focused on in the West Midlands is
reskilling retraining and that's the
real answer then you don't need to draw
in people in the way in which
historically we've been over dependent
and the other thing that I think is one
of those kind of big economic issues
that's been wrestling with is our
relationship with China I was quite
interested to hear if she's seen it this
morning saying China poses the biggest
danger of our age is he right or do we
actually need to do business with China
so the answer is both so let me just
explain of course he's right when he
says it's the biggest challenge of our
age because it's going to be the world's
economic superpower it is a superpower
that contrary to the relationship with
the US that has been the superpower for
the last hundred years does not share
our values that is obvious and so you do
have to think as a United West how are
we going to adjust tackle that issue my
opinion is it does not mean you
ostracize them completely and do not
deal with them economically but you have
to be absolutely alert so this question
about critical National infrastructure
who's owning that it's absolutely the
right thing to call out but it has to be
a policy of Engagement and what's your
view on taxes as well I know I'm doing
kind of like a jump everywhere yeah
they're going everywhere you know it's
rare that I get you in the studio so I'm
always Keen to kind of put your brains
on stuff
um what's your view on the levels of
taxes historically they're very high at
the minute lots of discontinent among
the conservative party do they need to
come down and which ones would you focus
on so no one's questioning the fact that
taxes are very high by historical
standards why because we've come through
a pandemic have spent an enormous amount
of money you've got to adjust to that
but the sad lesson of last Autumn is if
you do it in in an unplanned way you
just can't we'll be called out by the
markets so what the chance was said is
right he wishes to bring them down will
as soon as as he can as soon as the
public finances improve and where would
you go first I would definitely go to
business taxation first because actually
you stand back and say where's the
growth in the economy going to come from
it is only through businesses investing
and so that I think is the right thing
for him to have absolutely in his sights
and when you say business taxes
corporation tax or what is there any
corporation tax business rates are still
very challenging in many many areas
business rates and as the economy
adjusts there are areas that are really
stranded with their business rates so
that's an area where I hope we can move
but investment allowances uh would be
which are good they could move even
further it is as you say a very
challenging time for businesses at the
minute including John Lewis under quite
a lot of pressure I know you can do I'm
always interested to get your views on
as a former boss of John Lewis
um how how difficult is the situation
that it finds us well the situations
seven years
but never mind I can I can I can give
you a view if you ask a straight
question you need a straight answer so
it's very it's tough for retailers
everybody knows that but there are
wonderful success stories if I just look
at Birmingham we've got Savages got
private we've got next We've Got Jake
Sports Direct all with Flagship shops it
can be done and you just have to focus
on delighting your customers sounds so
simplistic but in the good days of John
Lewis that is what was being done with
the best product the best service in the
marketplace uh now just finally and I
know that you will have a reason to not
know about this story I wouldn't expect
you to be texting swella Brotherman this
morning to find out the truth of whether
or not she did our civil servants to
organize the speed awareness course
but as a conservative you know fighting
in marginal areas for your position
how damaging are these stories I I you
almost answer your own questions Sophie
I cannot possibly know about this I've
literally heard it this morning uh but I
mean the point is very simple there have
to be standards in public life and I'm
not going to sit here and make a comment
about them I genuinely do not know what
I do know is the prime minister has made
it absolutely clear that for him
standards in public life is an
absolutely critical issue I hope that's
how I conduct myself I hope that's how
my party conducts itself but there is no
compromise over it because the public
sniff out when you are not doing that
and if we serve the public we have to
reflect their best standards and of
course he said it and he promised a
government visibility and he's he's been
uh man to that thank you very much
indeed always really good to talk to you
on the program this morning thank you
very much I understood that now of the
West Midlands
is for the first time at the largest
party in local governments in Northern
Ireland the Nationalist party gained an
extra 39 Council seats and demanded that
power sharing should be restarted well
the storm assembly has been suspended
after the dep walked away because the
post-brexit training arrangements with
the rest of the UK well we can talk now
to our senior Island correspondent David
Bevins David always such a pleasure to
have you on the program
um Sinn Fein say the victory is historic
how significant is it
yes good morning Sophie it would be
difficult if not impossible to overstate
the significance of this result for shin
Fein it's not just the largest party in
the Northern Ireland assembly at
Stormwind for the first time it is now
the largest party of local government
for the first time winning a record
number of seats across 11 councils here
a greater number of states than any
party before it now however you analyze
that it is a seismic shift in the
political landscape of Northern Ireland
and of this island when you consider
that we now have a shin Fein first
Minister designated Stormwind in the
form of Michelle O'Neill and given the
polls South of the Border the very real
potential for Mary Lou McDonald to be
the next Irish Prime Minister the next
t-shirt so if you had a shin Fein
t-shirt in Dublin and a shin Fein first
minister in Belfast anyone suggesting
that we're not witnessing historic
change really is kidding themselves
absolute historic as you say and the key
question that many people will be asking
is whether this makes any difference at
all to the running of stormwatch do you
think it could get back up and running
well I'm going to hedge my bets and say
probably but it's not a foregone
conclusion and that's because this
election was about shin Fein winning
more than it was about the dup losing um
the dup despite predictions of meltdown
in their vote over the boycott apart
sharing at Stormont held their own in
most constituencies in fact they made
some gains the only reason Shin fan has
done so well is that it has stolen so
many states from the moderate sdlp the
other nationalist party a clear
indication that nationalists are
frustrated with the dup for blocking
Michelle O'Neill from holding the office
of first minister at Stormwind but Shin
fein's not taking seats from the dup
they're taking them from the other
nationalist party and the dup will
therefore argue that they still have a
mandate for the Hardline position
they've adopted in opposition to
post-brexit trading Arrangements
zoom out from
it that we're now
the largest party in local governments
in Northern Ireland
they've been a bit of rebranding I guess
of chimpan under the leadership of Mary
Lou McDonald and Michelle O'Neill
oh absolutely just think about the
journey that the party has come on LED
for 35 years by Jerry Adams without
question the world's most recognizable
Irish Republican and by Martin McGinnis
a self-confessed former Ira Commander
but of course he did cross the political
Rubicon when he shared power with his
political Nemesis the unionist leader
the Reverend Ian Paisley and
historically reached out to shake hands
with her majesty the queen but they've
gone even further now because those two
men have been succeeded by two women a
complete Rebrand for shin Fein Mary Lou
McDonald in Dublin Michelle O'Neill here
in double in Belfast and two women who
are fronting much more populist social
policies so they're not just holding on
to their Irish Republican base they are
appealing to a whole new generation of
Voters and to more moderate voters who
perhaps recognize the chin fian is in
the process of fully moving away from
its past 30 years ago some might say
have and completed the journey from the
men with guns to the women in government
always really interesting to talk as you
say a really extraordinary week in
Northern Ireland thank you very much
David blevinsel
now we often more often than we'd like
uh talk about bad behavior by
politicians on this program but the
world of business has been rocked by
allegations of misconduct by high
profile senior Executives in recent
years this week the term Tesco John
Allen stepped down from one of the top
jobs in British business following
allegations and just weeks after the
director general of the UK's biggest
business organization the CBI was sacked
or we're joined Now by baroness modeling
Fox who is president of the British
Chambers of Commerce thank you so much
for being on the program you've had such
an extraordinary CV in career not just
president of the British changes of
Commerce but it was a chair of we
transfer non-executive director of
Chanel Chancellor of the open University
a Serial entrepreneur who set up
lastminute.com
um absolutely great to have you on lots
that I want to talk to you about but if
I may just to start with what's
happening when it comes to the culture
in business at the minute because we
have seen these very high profile
allegations is there problem with the
behavior of senior people in business in
the UK
that's a that's a big question good
morning Sophie lovely to be here I think
for me it's a couple of things you know
we clearly have now got the ability to
have conversations and race issues that
perhaps before we brush under the carpet
you know as women as people who felt
vulnerable minorities whatever it might
be I do think how I've got to be careful
to separate very very serious
allegations of rape and sexual
misconduct from what might be determined
as behavior in the office that may be
inappropriate might be old-fashioned
might be much more um complex on picks I
just think it's important to separate
those different things but to me it's a
big shift from when I first started in
business and you couldn't even say if
you thought somebody was being a bit
tricky with you or a bit inappropriate
um I can imagine that it must have been
a big shift and you're right that we are
much more able to call out behavior that
is inappropriate now than perhaps
um previously and as you say you've been
in business for many years and you've
probably witnessed or experienced stuff
over your time there so feel free to
share and any experiences but I
understand if not do you think things
are improving
uh I I think they are on one level and
uh I can tell you thousands of funny
stories I think everybody uh has
probably
um had a story um or something happened
to them every woman in business you know
everything from when we started
lastminute.com and investor the only
investor that would see me in Brent the
co-founder for and meeting about whether
or not to invest in our business the
first question which he directed at
Brent was what happens if she me gets
pregnant which still shocks me now 25 30
years later but I hear stories all the
time with other people suffering way
worse things than that you know I've had
people call out my clothes how I look
all the time it's endless in it but I do
think it shifted I do think it's much
more um careful in most business
environments and uh I think that we just
have to recognize that well people like
me might still be very lucky and have
the ability to say things are not quite
right or call out somebody if they're
bad behavior you know we need to focus
on the most vulnerable people in
workplaces if you're a contractor in a
cleaning company working nights from a
minority I don't know where the power
feels as though it's different for you
so I think it's really important we
think about the whole spectrum of people
who work and as always look after and
protect the most vulnerable
yeah I absolutely agree with that
actually and it is easy for women in
high profile positions to talk about
things getting better is it getting
better for the people who don't have the
loudest voices I think is the question
as you say that we do need to keep
asking
there's been all sorts of allegations
around the CBI and I think you're right
to say that it's important to say that
there's a range of allegations here
um do you think that organization has
now finished
you know I don't know nobody wants to
dance on another organization's grave
especially when they've been
reports of bad behavior you know what I
would say is that at this moment in time
it's incredibly important to have the
voice of business
effectively talking into government
chair I'm sorry president of the British
members of Commerce as you said we're a
160 year old organization with members
from local communities represented at a
national level and Global Network as
well and we had our conference this week
on Wednesday and we had the chancellor
there we had the governor of the bank of
England we had Kia stamas so we are
there we are carrying on doing our job
and so the voice of business is being
represented into government and we feel
really strongly that pre-election with
so much happening in the economy that
the government of all shades and both
sides are listening to what business has
to say and their concerns about the next
18 months two years
what is your number one message to the
government
I think I'm gonna get cheeky and kind of
safety things I think firstly it's
incredibly important that it's
incredibly important that government
recognizes business feels uncertain
businesses are not looking ahead and
thinking yup the economy feels robust
and yup I feel confident in the
political situation as we've seen
repeatedly in all the data shows whether
it's data about business confidence
whether it's data about actual
investment businesses are waiting
they're kind of feeling a bit uncertain
and holding back and that's bad we need
business to feel confident to feel as
though there is stability to feel as
though they know what the shape of the
next two years is going to be like so
that they can invest that's fundamental
the second thing is around the people's
crisis that we have in this country you
know we we don't have enough people for
the jobs that we want to do we've got
million people uh who have vacancies in
their business it's the single biggest
thing that I hear from talking to
businesses all over the country in my
role British members of Commerce it's
unbelievably complicated to find some
people in some sectors to then retain
them to retrain them and so on so I
really do think it's a people's crisis
and I hope that the government and the
opposition parties are listening to that
because it's the thing that people come
back to again and again when I'm
traveling around talking to businesses
across the country it's really
interesting to hear what you describe as
a people's crisis at a time when there's
a lot of focus on net migration figures
um out next week which is UNIX says he
wants them to come down you know in the
show a couple weeks ago I spoke to the
former um Bank of England Chief
Economist Andy howdain who said that
actually the government needs to
alleviate some of those pressures
through skilled controlled migrant labor
do you think he's right that actually we
need to embrace more immigration to try
and fill some of those gaps
I 100 do and I think the businesses that
we represent in the chamber Network
would say the same thing we have some of
the Frameworks there already we've got
the Frameworks around short-term
Contracting work for specially skilled
jobs they need to be expanded wrapped up
scaled up and we won't be able to power
up the economy in the way that I think
is possible in this country if we don't
have the people both in our country and
outside our country it's got to be both
it can't be one or the other and if we
shrink and we become closed it's not
going to be good for any of us not for
consumers not for um Business Leaders
it's it's really important that we
address this
um incredible Gap in skills that we have
is it made worse after leaving the
European Union
I think so yes I think it would be very
tricky to argue that this has become an
issue that we've sorted out internally
you know and I don't want to give the
impression that anybody that I talk to
believes we shouldn't be training up and
working hard to make sure that the
people in this country have the skills
we need as well they do need to happen
in parallel we need to make sure we've
got skilled workers from overseas we
also need to make sure that we're
helping our own uh citizens and
employees become as skilled as possible
and also charts for the open University
I think this time and time again now
people are using that organization to
skill up in their work and move on in
their careers and it's it's vital that
we we have dual track in this in order
to address the enormous challenges that
we face over the next decade it's
interesting you mentioned the
universities there as well because it
does feel that this is another part of
the political debate about whether the
rules should be tightened on
International students and the time that
they can stay in the UK after finishing
a course do you think that's something
the government could look at
okay
so you slightly cut out their services I
hope I'm answering the right question
but uh I hope you talk about
universities and you know I agree I
think we also think um at the University
that it's super important that we keep
open and bringing people to study and
keep that richness of our open
University but also the wider University
Network we just don't want to become a
closed country whatever you feel about
the brexit debate I think that it's been
really important that Britain still
feels as though it's a place that has
these centers of excellence that is
encouraging people from all over the
world to to come in and out of our
country to see the incredible
um university Network that we have and
use it and feel part of it because
that's an incredible soft power that
we'll have over the world when we
um keep those borders open so from every
angle I think you know we would argue
that for all the institutions that I'm
lucky enough to represent but an open
Britain is in a very important player on
the world stage we mustn't become too
closed
and politics has already kind of gearing
up for an election next year and it
feels like there's a bit of a tussle
between labor and the conservatives over
who is the party for business who do you
think is coming out on top at the minute
I think it it was definitely I mean I
think the great thing is that both
parties are talking actively about
business and the importance of engaging
with businesses you know 30 of the
people in this country work in
businesses they fuel our economy we're
not going to have any of the ability to
deliver services and the things that we
want to do if we don't have a robust uh
economy and that's driven by business so
it was fantastic that both kirstana and
Jeremy Hunt and Andrew Bailey were at
our conference at the BCC on Wednesday
all of them are talking about the
importance of business everybody's
talking about growth as always you know
we want to see the action behind that we
want to feel as though it's not just
noise but it's also follow through with
action and as I talked about making that
a business environment feel certain
making sure that we've got the skills we
need helping businesses trade
internationally and so forth there's a
bunch of stuff that needs to happen as
well as the rhetoric but the first point
is clearly to make sure that parties are
listening and engaging and that's 100
happening
and thanks very much it's been really
interesting to talk to you about a whole
range of things this morning so thank
you for being on the program
uh that was baroness at mother Lane Fox
talking to the program and now we've
talked quite a lot recently about AI
article and artificial intelligence I
can get my words out um just a few weeks
ago on the program we had a start
warning from one of the world's leading
AI computer scientists about some
serious risks and our group of school
leaders have sent out their fears about
the threat it poses to education
including leading State and private
school heads and University leaders now
they've been led by the renowned
historian and the head of epson college
that Anthony Selden who joins us now
thank you very much for being on the
program
what is the threats of AI when it comes
to education
so can I just hear that question again
sorry just a bit more clearly there's
some noise of course apologies for the
disruption what is the threats of
artificial intelligence to education
well there I think there are many more
opportunities uh unrivaled opportunities
to give all young people regardless of
the schools they're in and the parts of
the country they're in and indeed the
learning difficulties that they might
have extraordinary opportunities for
enrichment for real-time assessment uh
and and marking to free up teachers to
spend much more time with young people
because a lot of the heavy lifting will
be done by the machines but they're also
very real risks
um risks of obviously plagiarism uh
risks that all the difficult parts will
be taken over by the technology which is
only in its infancy at the moment the
rate of change is going to be uh
incredible over the next five and ten
years as we've already seen
and and fear of deep fakes of uh of of
moral uh damage uh to young people which
is already quite considerable with
social media uh will be magnified
because of the uh the extraordinary case
of change and schools teachers parents
we're all bewildered
it's interesting to use that word are
you taught there about the use of deep
fakes and is that something that you're
seeing in your schools amongst young
people like it's almost feels to me like
another tool of bullying that people
could choose
yeah I mean uh it is uh extremely
invidious uh and uh dangerous how uh
manipulating uh the technology can be
because it will uh understand I mean as
we know uh when we're shopping uh uh
when we're looking on the internet the
personalization of the material that
comes to us will become far far more
sophisticated and young people are young
they can't negotiate the world very well
and uh so the opportunity for them to be
manipulated bullied uh brought into
practices uh drugs all the rest of it
um it is very worrying to parents very
worrying to schools so what we're saying
is look
um the edtech companies
um have a lot of profit motive they're
making enormous amounts of money out of
the technology
um that we can't make them go away we
have to ensure that we provide uh
parents schools uh teachers with really
good information about what is wholesome
uh stimulating good Ai and what uh
people should be aware of because
government uh who really have caught up
in the last few months but they're still
behind the curve and they never quite
understand what happens in schools
Parliament doing some good work but they
take a lot of time to to to come out
with their statutes and recommendations
we have to take it into our own hands
schools to ensure that human
intelligence uh is at the very heart of
schools artificial intelligence will
never take over from humans as long as
we put human intelligence first and
don't uh just try teaching young people
with tests and exams in a way that is
giving them the skills that the
algorithms will always be better as
Martha Lane Fox was talking about we
need the skills in this country and
skills are the interpersonal skills the
human skill the the problem solving the
entrepreneurial skills uh which uh which
are not being sufficiently done in
schools because we're just narrowing
everything down to exams so I think that
there is a lot here that is enormously
exciting but we have to get ahead of it
uh in the interests of the children and
the many uh not the few parents teachers
you mentioned the interview with Martha
Lane Fox um she was also very strongly
saying that the government shouldn't be
looking at International students to try
and get net migration figures down
what's your view on that
well I think universities are doing I
mean I would do wouldn't I used to be a
vice Chancellor I I are doing a superb
job uh government have failed to provide
the leadership of the sector uh
universities should be right at the very
heart of that drive for productivity
that Martha was talking about
um but if uh without a more benign
attitude from government if Government
stays obsessed by
um but by numbers
of overseas students who so enrich this
country and the economy in Britain's
relations with the world it's it's just
um looking at the wrong thing government
really isn't smart about the leadership
of Education
education or school or school education
they're obsessed by narrow data whether
immigration numbers or whether exam
results they really don't get what
education is all about and they
certainly don't get AI sufficiently yet
that's really interesting to hear your
thoughts on it um I'm interested as the
head of um Epson College because there
has been a bit of a debate about private
schools particularly among the labor
party uh kirstama saying that he would
abolish the charitable status of private
schools levy VAT on fees what's your
reaction to that
well
um I think that um that this initiative
here uh that we're talking about is
cross-sector between its jointly led by
Epsom and uh by a multi-academy trust
born academy is the example of
collaborative work between independent
and state schools which I think is the
model for the future personally I don't
think that getting rid of Independent
Schools or putting so much Financial
squeeze on them will actually help at
State schools I think working together
side by side is the way forward and I
think that that is what we'll see
because if Independent Schools have to
close there simply aren't the places in
the state schools to take all those
young people so let's have a a much more
imaginative policy from government and a
much more forward-thinking policy for
government
and let's see both both sides of that
education divide working much more
closely together that's always
you think there's a genuine risk of
independent schools closing then
yeah and I think it's going to be
particularly those uh which are serving
areas uh where there is lesser income uh
whether these are already lower where
the um the margins are much tighter and
where those schools are serving
um really serving their communities and
giving
parents another choice I think it's good
that we don't have a uniform education
system that there is choice and
diversity within it I think that is the
strength of the British education system
it's why overall and historically we've
had such a good education system so
um you know who will see look Labor uh
out of power uh before 1945 or 1960 Ford
before 1997 has always made threatening
noises about wanting to get rid of
Independent Schools and of course I
understand that argument but when it
gets into power and the practicalities
bite in
um that they do other things and that
they go off in other areas I think much
better to try and raise the standards of
all state schools not the least by
understanding government understanding
what AI is and how it can give a top
quality education to all and to have
both sectors working together I think
that's a better way myself
and just finally talked a bit about the
choice that parents have um Rachel
Reeves said Shadow Chancellor said she
wouldn't send her children to private
school because she wants them in her
words to see the world as it is do you
think she's got a point
yeah I I think
um that a lot of Labor ministers
historically have always sent their
children to Independent Schools there
are some superlative
State schools I think the best of State
schools are better than Independent
Schools but I think also that's a little
bit unfair to some of the incredibly
imaginative Independent Schools but
you're doing things uh to stretch and
give their young people opportunities
which the more uh which there simply
isn't the the time often in a state
school to do but look that's right she's
exercising her choice
um good for her and
personally we send our children at
different times to both state and to
Independent Schools we have a fantastic
State sector which has got better and
better
um thank you so much for being on the
program it's been really fascinating to
hear your views and I think the warning
on artificial intelligence you know to
government and also to the companies is
one that's very timely indeed very real
very real
uh thank you
well that is it for this week's at safer
Ridge on Sunday but in a moment after
the break we'll be running through
today's interviews we'll be joined by
our political correspondent Liz Bates
thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back this is Sophia Ridge
on Sunday the take a chance for us to
look back at our interviews this morning
on the program work out what we've
learned what it means for the week ahead
uh we're joined uh today with our
political correspondent at Liz Bates but
just to start off because it was one of
these programs where you know you think
you know what you're going to be uh
asking uh about you know you think it's
going to be all about the G7 or perhaps
on Ukraine and obviously there was
questions on that but then you had the
sort of bong Xiao Sunday Times uh story
about suela bravam and the Home
Secretary and the allegation that she
asked civil servants to help set up a
private speed awareness course to try
and avoid having points on her license
now it's one of these things where you
kind of know that the minister on the
program is going to try and Dodge the
question and the challenges an
interviewer is to try and pin them down
or at least to try and hold them to
account or on why they don't have the
answers
um let's have a quick listen shall we to
Therese coffee at the environment
secretary what she had to say when I
asked her about those allegations
It's Perfectly Normal nowadays if people
are found speeding to be offered points
or to go on a course of some kind
um so I say I don't know the details
that are referred to in the newspaper
but I think uh as far as I'm aware the
home secretary's just decided to take
the points pay the penalty and uh keep
focused on her main job of um uh
security but also tackling illegal
migration do you have the home
secretary's phone number
do I have her phone number I probably do
somewhere uh why didn't you message them
well because I think it's a case of uh
there's some speculation newspaper I'm
not going to get into individual details
um as far as I'm aware there's people
close to the message so whoever the the
Press but you know candidly this is just
a case of um something that happened I
guess over a year ago I don't quite know
the details I can only read what is I'm
only aware of what was in the newspaper
well let's bring in our political cross
when Elizabeth
I mean look I guess I was kind of
expecting her to be like look I don't
need the details but I was quite struck
by just how far she went in there saying
yeah I have a number but I don't want to
message someone at 7 20 in the morning
it's like well it is the Home Secretary
being accused of something that is
potentially quite serious no yeah and it
was quite extraordinary I thought that
exchange because this is something that
we saw uh over and over again
particularly under the Boris Johnson
Administration which was and I know that
you tried to come up with different
questions at the time to try and get at
some of those issues which is why you
asked Trace coffee this morning about
whether she had solar bravman's phone
number we see ministers coming on these
programs and saying well I don't know
anything about it and I think you're
completely right to say well why can't
you text her and her defense for that
seemed to be that maybe it was too early
on a Sunday morning and even maybe the
suggestion that the Home Secretary isn't
up on a Sunday morning reading some of
the newspapers that she's on the front
of and I think this is an issue that we
have to get around with ministers
because they come on these programs to
be accountable for what's going on in
government and I think it's it's time to
if we can to end that practice of just
saying I don't know anything about it
I'm just reading it in the newspapers
um like everybody else especially
because Rishi sunat really drew a line
in the sand I think on this issue
himself this didn't come from us this
came from him he said this was going to
be a government and a Premiership that
was
centered around integrity and
professionalism and high standards and
so I think ministers need to be more
accountable for that yeah it's also the
sort of frustration where I think at one
point she was like look you just making
all these allegations it's like I'm
actually genuinely just trying to find
out what happened because the statement
from swallow Brotherman also doesn't
address this it just says that she took
the points and at one point Terese
coffee was trying to say I think um look
she just was trying to get a speed
awareness course this happens all the
time she took points this happens all
the time but that's not the allegation
is it that's not the central allegations
that she taught civil servants no and I
think we can see quite clearly already
what the line from the government is
because this is a line that's come from
swella Braverman which is
um it happened I've dealt with it and
Trace coffee had the same line as well
she's accepted what's happened and she's
paid the fine taking the points prime
minister said it as well this morning
this line is not going to hold because
it's answering a different question
nobody's accusing her of speeding it's
quite clear that that happened it it is
the possibility that she approached
civil servants which is entirely
inappropriate on a matter like this to
try and bend the rules for yourself
that's the question that they need to
answer and look
there is a process there's a ministerial
code there's an Ethics advisor there's a
there is ways to get to the bottom of
this and I think the government will be
facing many more questions on this I
don't think this line uh can I don't
think they can keep trotting out this
line can I ask you a bit of a bubble
question a West Mr Bubble question
timing of this happened last year it's
been leaked
the Sunday before the net migration
figures come out which is going to be a
really difficult time for Home Secretary
right really difficult time perhaps her
hardest week
I mean that looks a bit deliberate
doesn't it in what sense well someone's
got it in for it
yes I mean look I think there's there's
always a possibility of that whenever
um
a lot of the time in Westminster when
stories get leaked to journalists it's
not all to journalists it's not always
purely for public good sometimes there
are political reasons behind it in the
end it doesn't matter because these
things must come to light it's important
for standards in public life but yes I
think the timing is a bit suspicious
where's my eyebrow although as you say
it's clearly a public interest or an
important story to come out no one is
questioning that but I just I did just I
did just make me thinks like
um now labor are calling for an
investigation into whether the Home
Secretary broke the ministerial code um
Shadow Health Minister Liz Kendall says
that if she has it wouldn't be entirely
surprising
I think Rishi sunac should launch an
investigation into it he should ask the
independent advisor whether she's
breached the standards of the
ministerial code here I think a lot of
people watching this program will think
you know why is it always one rule for
them and another rule for everybody else
but you know Zoella bravaman's got got
form on this hasn't she you'll remember
she actually had to resign as home
secretary under Liz truss because she
sent confidential documents to atori MP
when she shouldn't have done that and
Rishi sunak reappointed her as Home
Secretary why because he had to keep the
right wing of his party on board so
there's no point in him getting all
techy at the G7 press conference
it's it's because of him that she's
there so I've got my own views about
that sort of behavior but actually what
she what he should do is launch an
investigation to make sure we get to the
bottom of this
and it's an open goal for labor really
isn't it yeah and the other thing is I
think that Liz Kendall is kind of
touching on
um something which is quite obvious
which is look it's not a I don't think
anybody thinks that it's a perfect fit
swella Braven in Rishi sunak's cabinet
but she backed him in the leadership
contest he made her home secretary to
some extent he really needs her
especially at the moment off the back of
the local elections he's looking on
Shaky Ground I think within his party
there are grumblings there are tensions
and what she does is she secures the
backing of that
um that wing of the party that has been
very difficult and has made problems for
previous governments the ERG and so I
think that is why he will back her in
this scenario and again as Liz Kendall
said you know she had form at the time
she'd only just broken the ministerial
code
um at the time when he brought her back
into cabinet so uh I I think it's going
to be this is going to be a tricky
political issue for him it's true and
it's quite important to reflect that
isn't it I think that often you know in
London or in kind of Westminster bubble
whatever you end up saying that look
everyone thinks that swella pravaman is
unpopular no one backs her why is she in
cabinet but actually if you look at
conservative members she's very popular
yes she's very popular within the
conservative party in a specific Wing
within the conservative party and that
is why I think Rishi sunak will try to
hang on to her
um and I think we'll see this we'll see
this playing out but as I said he again
there are competing ends here because he
did set himself the task of running a
very different type of government when
it came to these types of issues and you
saw him he'd be very decisive previously
on Nadim zahari when it came to his
financial issues on Dominic Rabb and the
bullying report that came out so we'll
see whether he's prepared to take action
uh and uh and just launch an
investigation ask his ethics advisor on
this issue as well Brotherman or if
politics Will trump the kind of high
standards in public life that he said
that he's going to go forward with and
what's interesting Liz was just talking
there about the kind of competing sort
of factions and wings in the
conservative party and I have to say we
spoke to the conservative mayor of the
West Midlands and his street on the
program today and we asked him about
swella bravaman just have a listen to he
said I think this is quite interesting
I mean the point is very simple there
have to be standards in public life uh
I'm not going to sit here and make a
comment about the Home Secretary I
genuinely do not know what I do know is
the prime minister has made it
absolutely clear that for him standards
in public life is an absolutely critical
issue I hope that's how I conduct myself
I hope that's how my party conducts
itself but there is no compromise over
it because the public sniff out when you
are not doing that and if we serve the
public we have to reflect their best
standards
I mean he said he wasn't commenting
directly on the Home Secretary but
but punch you I thought actually yes
um I think he he went in a completely
different direction from Trey's coffee
and like it doesn't take much to read
between the lines of that to say uh that
he is on the side of
um going down a different route which is
pretend potentially kind of looking into
the type of behavior that has gone on
here what we see when it comes to the
kind of the Mayors is that they do have
a bit more scoped kind of freelance on
these issues and as he said he's not in
cabinet he's not going to see swella
braveman he may not even have her phone
number to ask her but he is taking a
different approach and I think for Andy
street that will be about what voters
think you could see him there saying you
know people can sniff this out and I
think under certainly under Boris
Johnson these issues were muddier the
ministerial code the ethics advisor
um the way that he approached these
issues with his cabinet ministers and
Andy street is of the view that things
need to be different under issue now so
you can see him sort of gently shoving
him in that direction yeah it's quite
interesting isn't it I always enjoy
talking to because he is someone who's
very deeply connected with a very
marginal area of the country and he was
saying correctly that actually the
conservatives did outperform I mean low
Baseline obviously but in the in the
West Midlands compared to elsewhere at
those local elections yeah
um thanks very much for analysis on
swalla bravaman uh Liz now another
really big talking point at the moment
on the show this morning is migration
with those figures that we're expecting
next week and reports suggesting that
net migration could top a
record-breaking 700 000 people
um truce coffee didn't share her
thoughts on what the actual number might
be ahead of it coming out let's listen
I'm not going to speculate on what's uh
make the statistics may be coming I
think there are two key points that I'd
like to make which are that since
leaving European Union we now control
through an Australian style points-based
system
um the criteria for people coming into
this country
um who don't already have the
opportunity to do so we've also opened
our doors to people from Hong Kong from
Ukraine in really difficult
circumstances so the point is the rules
are there if we decide that we want to
change the laws in the future but
overall the Prime Minister has been
clear he wants to reduce overall numbers
on legal migration but the main focus
right now is actually on tackling the
illegal immigration
let's bring in uh Liz well she's gonna
soon I could always talk about his five
pleasures and a lot of them are quite
easy like inflation for example that's
going to come down all the experts are
saying this year anyway but when it
comes to his comments on migration it's
actually very difficult to do isn't it
yeah and you can see again and again
which you see like he's doing it and his
ministers are doing it as well they're
wanting to talk about illegal migration
I think because they feel that in the
time frame they have until the next
general election that could be an easier
issue to tackle especially when you look
at the figures on legal migration but
look this is a um a political issue that
the conservative party have made many
pledges on in the past and I think it's
fair to say have have used in the past
to
um to appeal to voters so they can't
really shy away from it now that the
figures are going in the wrong direction
I think you could see playing out there
with Trey's coffee what is probably
going on in cabinet which is the
practicality
of bringing down these immigration
numbers at the same time as competing
goals in other sections of government in
particular you know you look at the
economy it's quite clear that there are
huge gaps uh in the workforce and we
need workers to do those jobs and
training people domestically is
something that takes a long time
compared to having foreign workers do
those jobs and I think if you look at
Mrs United's goals on growth he wants to
bring down inflation all of those things
really rely on filling those skills gaps
even Trace coffee said look you know we
have gaps in the edge in the
agricultural sector we need people to
work now and I think that is the tension
that is going on behind the scenes and
it's interesting because on the program
as well you know we spoke to
um surrounding Selden in the education
sector and baroness modeling books in
the economic sector and they're both
saying look we really need these people
to come over whether it is international
students in our universities whether it
is workers to fill some of the vacancies
in the draft markets not an easy balance
and yet if you listen to label they're
actually saying kind of a similar thing
I thought Liz Kendall went further than
I thought she would saying that she
wanted or labor would like to see a neck
migration coming down to
I expect it to come down and it should
come down and I think the real issue
here is this that in Labor's
points-based immigration system we have
to tie up what we're seeing in terms of
a skills Gap in our population and
actually put in place the programs to
deal with that so that we don't have to
have the work visas that we're seeing at
the moment I mean just look at Health
and Social care that is the area where
the highest number of visas are being
issued at the moment but what does the
government do it cuts Medical School
places this year by three thousand
so that was Liz Kendall's view I also
asked the same question to Andy Street
about whether there's an argument that
higher migration could be a positive
thing for the economy
we do need skilled migrants in some key
areas so one of the sectors that the
government is talking a lot about at the
moment is the new industrial sectors
such as the electric vehicle sector we
do need people to come with those skills
but we actually have to deal with the
underlying issue about the lack of
skills in our own population so one of
the other things we're absolutely
focused on in the West Midlands is
reskilling retraining and that's the
real answer
uh well let's bring Liz back in I mean
the round's just going to reignite isn't
it next week yes I think it is and I do
think it's quite interesting the labor
party's position we see this
um time and again I mean it's almost
that they've taken the government's uh
basically the government's exact same
position which is they want to see net
migration figures come down but it's
quite tricky at the moment because of
the um the workplace
um the workplace needing uh extra staff
and their basic position is
um we will do it better and I I thought
you know Liz Kendall brought up another
area where we are struggling for
domestic workers in the NHS
um but Labor's plans will take a long
time so they are in exactly the same
position as the government and uh they I
don't think they have a policy that will
um sort of be a game changer on this
it's really interesting isn't it um it I
did actually think she might not be
quite as direct because quite often with
these direct questions about should
migration be higher or lower
um I've struggle to get response but it
did feel that actually she was being
quite firm saying that we would like to
see lower levels of migration yes and I
think the labor party has
um in the past had a difficult
relationship uh with migration and so
they have taken this uh position that
they want to say to voters you know
we'll bring it will bring migration uh
figures down as as well but I think
they're in the same position as the
government they don't want to put a
figure on it they see that the uh that
the graph is going up almost
exponentially and it's it's quite easy
for them you know a couple of years out
of a general election to say we'd like
to see it go in a different direction
without any real
solid plans to um to do it certainly in
the short term that's true we might see
a few a few more soil plans I guess on
the NHS and we'll have to wait for those
as well and thank you very much indeed
Liz on the program uh this morning
always good to talk to you and we'll
have more from Liz as well because our
podcaster podcast best bits of the
interviews plus analysis from me Liz and
Scott Beasley a show editor that will be
out later on today as well
busy week and have a feeling that next
week is going to be a pretty busy one as
well with those all-important net
migration figures uh coming out too
thanks very much for watching this
morning uh we'll be back on Wednesday
night for the take with Sophie Ridge and
then of course on Sunday as well have a
great rest of your weekend
foreign